packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
put your feet up for my perfect TV
dinners
[Music]
like all chefs good food is my life and
for me TV dinners are all about recipes
that are fuss-free quick and easy to
make so however busy you are you can
always knock up brilliant food my TV
dinners need minimum shopping and rely
on the staple ingredients you already
have in the cupboard so you can enjoy
incredible dishes whenever you want
starting with my delicious mushroom and
leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important to put the water on
first so you can just have it gently
simmering away ready for the pasta while
the water comes to the boil start the
sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
I want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that's
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks just take your
knife
and go down through the center turn it
over
and again into quarters
to get all that opening up and then just
rinse the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add all that leak
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now the secret is to get rid of that
water inside the leak as it Cooks down
all the water's gone you just settle
that really nice intense flavor
Garlic's gone nice and crispy now we're
gonna add a touch of chicken stocking
now
sheets are an unusual choice for a dish
like this but they work brilliantly
although any type of pasta you've got in
the cupboard will do
twist that pan that stops any pasta
actually sticking to the bottom of the
pan
chickens start to reduce down by half
and it almost delays the bottom of the
pan basically washed all that wonderful
flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up the bone let it simmer for three
to four minutes
now
the secret of the pasta is taking it out
a little early
so you've got that nice texture hold up
the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center is ready
turn the sauce down and lay
these beautiful sheets
lasagna into that sauce
I'm just going to turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb that goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
Infuse to serve I'm making a quick
bruschetta by toasting fresh to batter
bread two nice slices drizzle that and
olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
crust as well crust is what really takes
that garlic
now
pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's in
stained by that amazing sauce to serve
or a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then I'll take my pasta
twist it and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
Bread on and that's the beauty about
something so simple they can be done in
20 minutes with everyday ingredients a
stunning pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so you can always
make great tasting food at the drop of a
hat
with foolproof pasta recipes up your
sleeve you'll always be able to knock up
a fantastic lunch or supper here are
three more of my super fast pasta dishes
that are bursting with flavor and
cooking minutes
kicking off with Buffalo with ricotta
pancetta and peas
[Music]
start by frying lardens in a large pan
these smoked chunks of bacon have a
delicious deep salty flavor that makes
them perfect with pasta when the lardens
start to Brown add finely chopped garlic
and turn off the heat
next at far Valley to Boiling salted
water
named after the Italian for butterflies
this bow tied shaped pasta has a large
surface area great for sticking to
sauces
just before the pasta is ready add
frozen peas to The Boiling pasta water
then when the pasta and the peas are
cooked drain and add to the lardens and
the garlic
spooning creme fraiche
[Music]
and Dot with lumps of creamy ricotta
cheese season
then serve
ready in just 12 minutes
for valley with ricotta pancetta and
peas a delicious quick and easy supper
that's ready when you are
[Music]
my next Pronto pasta dish is taglitelli
with quick sausage meat Bolognese
[Music]
first ball dry tagged Italian salted
water these long thin ribbons of pasta
come curled up in Ness and take around
10 minutes to cook then add olive oil to
a hot pan
fry finely chopped onion
thinly sliced garlic and sweat until
soft
[Music]
next remove the meat from your sausages
by cutting open their skins and crumble
into the pan
fennel or Sicilian sausages are perfect
for this dish but any flavored sausage
will do
when the meat has browned add half
cherry tomatoes season
[Music]
and add a few spoonfuls of the pasta
cooking water as the starch thickens the
sauce and helps it stick to the pasta
drain the taglitelli and add to the
sausage meat sauce
finish with freshly grated Parmesan
[Music]
perfect when you're really busy but
still want great tasting food fast my
amazing taglitelli with quick sausage
meat Bolognese
my final pasta dish that's ready in a
Flash and packs a real flavor punch
it's spaghetti with chili sardines and
oregano
[Music]
crunchy topping heat olive oil in a
frying pan add chopped garlic
and breadcrumbs
[Music]
cook over medium heat until the
breadcrumbs are golden
season
and drain on kitchen paper
for the sauce add the oil from your
sardines to a hot pan
fry finely diced chili
and chopped garlic
next cook dry spaghetti in boiling water
then chop tin sardines into chunks and
add to the chili and garlic tin sardines
are a brilliantly versatile ingredient
to have in your cupboard packed with
protein full of super healthy omega-3
oils and delicious
next drain your pasta and combine with
the Sardine chili and garlic mixture
add leaves of fresh oregano
mix in handfuls of Rocket
to serve part high and top with a crispy
garlic bread crumbs
[Music]
ready in under 15 minutes spaghetti with
chili sardines and oregano healthy
hearty and full of flavor perfect Pasta
in moments
[Applause]
whether you're rushing to put your feet
up in front of the Telly and need
something fast and tasty for the family
or somebody wants something delicious to
enjoy these are three amazing pasta
recipes you can learn by heart and cook
in minutes
beautiful
[Music]
now here are five more of my Essential
cooking tips starting with how to cook
an ingredient that's perfect for a quick
and easy TV dinner chicken breasts
this has to be the most popular part of
the chicken now it's very versatile
incredibly tender very lean hardly any
fat whatsoever the secret is cooking it
without it becoming dry
the first thing is to season it properly
both sides
two tablespoons of olive oil
get the pan nice and hot
the secret now
is to get a really nice color on the
skin really nice color
no color no flavor skin side down tilt
the pan so it Cooks the back of the
chicken breast where it's really nice
and round and very fat
let the pan do the work
chicken breast normally takes between
sort of 10 and 12 minutes to cook
properly
now we've got the color on the skin the
Skin's nice and crispy we're going to
deglaze the pan
these lays with masala now Masala is a
sweet fortified Italian wine you can
also use white wine
or Saladin
flambe
burn off the alcohol which gets rid of
that really sort of harsh alcoholic
flavor
roll the chicken around the masala
the glaze in the pan basically means
washing the pan
and lifting off all that flavor stuck to
the bottom of the frying pan and put it
into the sauce
now chicken stock
bring that up to the boil and let it
simmer for three to four minutes
[Music]
really important to leave the chicken
breasts skin side up the Skin's nice and
crispy and it's important now the
chicken Cooks from underneath as it
starts cooking it absorbs the stock so
in the center of the chicken stays nice
and moist
[Music]
now the stock of the masal is reduced
down you can have the confidence to
allow it to almost disappear
and look
the combination between the Masala and
the chicken stock is quite sweet so it
finishes the chicken with this really
nice delicious glaze on top
and there you go a delicious succulent
chicken breast with the most amazing
flavoursome skin phenomenal
soups make stunningly simple meals my
tip for adding incredible depth of
flavor is to always keep your leftover
parmesan rinds store them in the freezer
then add to the pan as the soup cooks
and leaves to infuse then remove before
serving is less waste and more taste
another tip to take homemade soup to the
next level whisking cubes of cold butter
just before serving to get a glossy
velvety texture and a beautifully Rich
taste another fantastic standard for a
fuss-free weekend eat is the classic
baked potato my tip for great crispy
skin is to use salt to your advantage
simply add it to the outside before
cooking and the salt will draw out the
moisture in the oven as it bakes a touch
of salt gives you an amazingly crisp
skin on chicken and fish too as well as
highlighting the flavor
foreign
roasted nuts make a delicious TV snack
my tip for peeling them with ease is to
Simply toast them in the oven for about
10 minutes wrapping a tea towel and rub
until the Skins are removed perfect
sprinkle with sea salt and so with a
glass of wine
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stake your life on coming up
I'll be showing you my amazing sweet
corn fritters that is such a delicious
recipe but first the key to whipping up
my ultimate TV dinners is having a
well-stocked store covered and even with
the basics like tin sardines Tomatoes
pasta or rice it always pays to know how
to buy the best
next up my shopping guide to All Things
pasta
foreign
Italian staple you'll be hard-pressed to
find anyone who knows more than pass the
Supremo Antonio sakamani
I love pastors so much I have to eat it
at least once a day please be selling
perfect Pasta in London Soho for over 35
years and eating great pasta for a
lifetime
we'll make the best pass in the world
Italy
take away the past in Italy and the
people died you know and that's it for a
good very good pasta you need two
ingredients you need a good act and very
good flower and that's it this is a
durum wheat flour look at that it's so
soft
then she cooks so quick a couple minutes
in the boiling water this thing like
this
couple minutes is cool
this shop is not it's not big enough to
store all the type of pasta this is the
foreign
this is penne different shape it's
called fujele
Antonio's right there's a mind-blowing
array of incredible pasta types that are
great to keep in your store cupboard
here's my quick guide to some of the
different shapes and sizes and how to
use them
small shapes like fafalini are perfect
for making simple stews and soups more
substantial and add an extra texture to
dishes like the classic Italian pasta
soup minestrone
short tubes like penne are great for
thick cream or tomato based sauces as
the rigid edges hold more sauce for an
incredibly flavor packed mouthful
long and thin like the store cupboard
essential spaghetti the classic shape
was invented in Naples but every Italian
region has its own spaghetti dish from
Bolognese to carbonara or my favorite a
la vangale which is spaghetti with
delicious steamed clams
flat noodles shaped strands like
fettuccine are perfect with a simple
drizzle of olive oil or in Rich buttery
dishes as a little sauce goes a long way
coating the pasta evenly stopping the
strands from sticking together
then pass the sheets not just great for
lasagna's but amazing rolled into tubes
and fill to make delicious Cannon lonely
or used in quick supper dishes like my
mushroom and leek pasta
finally specialty pastas like this
spaghetti made with Squid Ink as
definitely sweet taste and an amazing
jet black color great for when you want
a delicious dinner that's a little bit
different whatever shape you go for
always look out for the pastas that have
been bronze cut it means the dough was
pressed through a bronze cutting die
which has a subtle rough texture which
helps the sauce stick as well as all the
dried types pasta also comes fresh which
is brilliant for TV dinners because it
Cooks super quick and tastes incredible
too
in this shop we make pasta every day
look at that that's good
is sad to eat it this past is really
really yellow because we use good
quality of eggs you can smell the eggs
they come true
it's so good so fresh you can even
eat it roll like that it lasts in the
fridge two or three days you can even
freeze it and I won't change taste
whether fresh or dried pasta so
versatile and quick to cook is the
perfect TV dinner so go out stock up on
new shaves and you'll soon be turning
out dishes that would make pasta Pro
Antonio very proud it looks so nice so
good so healthy you know and then that's
it you can't resist
we all lead busy lives but that doesn't
mean you have to compromise when it
comes to cooking great food
for me the secret is having recipes you
can depend on and a stalker full of
staple ingredients that can be
transformed into Quick delicious dinners
on demand
so Shop Smart stock up and whether
you're feeding 2 or 20 you'll always be
ready to cook up something incredible my
next tasty dish uses simple and cheap
store covered ingredients with stunning
results and takes minutes to make sweet
corn fritters and yogurt dip it's
brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweet corn somewhere so I'm going to
show you how to make the most amazing
fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture take your flour
sieve really important to sieve the
flour that stops the mixture from having
any lumps in there
just before you get to the end I want to
put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift in
sieve that through
such a salt
and pepper
next an egg about four tablespoons of
milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture whisk that in make
sure you've got rid of all those lumps
so that we want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chili so give it a
really good
Shake
[Music]
tap them out slice in half into quarter
and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way
slicing a chili
into the mixture spring onion take off
that outside layer of the spring onion
top and tail slice at an angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture I want that nice
crunch
and coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the Sweet Corn Now drain it from
the tin and just Pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now I've got two thirds
ingredients and one third of the mixture
to bind together that's a secret of good
threader so you're you're biting into
excitement and not sort of dough pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in
space the fritters evenly around the pan
in a clockwise Direction so you always
know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit
okay
palette knife
just check
with the color
and turn over beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
[Music]
and then some fresh lime
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in give that a nice mix up
chili just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tennis sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to take your
life on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better Chef many of
these amazing recipes are on my app
please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on so sit
back and enjoy my delicious simple
suppers
one of my Essential mantras for becoming
a better cook is it's all about building
your confidence and the way to do that
is with practice
they have a repertoire of easy dishes
you want to cook and eat time and time
again and soon you'll be on your way to
becoming a kitchen demon
my first dish keeps it simple but
delivers big time on Flavor so it's sure
to become a regular quick supper fix
spicy tuna fish cakes I love this recipe
why because it turns this humble
ingredient a can of tuna into something
delicious
just open up
and drain the tuna into a sieve
slightly flaked out
don't press it too hard otherwise you'll
dry out the tuner
these are water chestnuts just slicing
nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
Supermarket chestnuts and fresh ginger
give her that rough skin on the outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that really nice
sort of juice
in
take your spring onions and just slice
on an angle I like the texture of the
water chestnut
with a spring onion
Touch of fresh coriander
lovely
next remove the seeds from a chili to
reduce its heat without losing any
flavor
and finely chop
chilies in
Cafe lime leaves roll them up nice and
tight run your knife down the center
once and just chop
and that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant
such as salt
a touch of pepper
fish sauce
just lightly seasoned
tuna
to bind all those one of the ingredients
two whole eggs
and give that a nice little whisk
foreign
and then
add your eggs keep your hands in there
start mixing
get the mixture
roll it from hand to hand in the Palm
Pat them down nicely
to cook add a little ground oil to a hot
pan at the face of a clock I'm going to
go from 12 all the way around
let's first one in
these fish cakes only take a few minutes
to cook so keeping track of the order
they go in the pan means you know which
one to turn first
[Music]
to the pal a nice gentle little Shake
make sure that nothing's sticking to the
bottom
spatula two fingers on top turn them
over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because the
tune is already cooked so we just
lightly frying and we get a nice crisp
outside and gently take them out
smell incredible
let them sit there I'm going to make a
really nice delicious simple dipping
sauce start off a little Pinch of Sugar
fish sauce two tablespoons that gives it
the saltiness
one tablespoon of rice wine vinegar
fresh lime juice
squeeze all that lime in there your
fresh coriander lots of coriander and
then
give that
a little mix
and then you have the most amazing spicy
tuna fish cakes who would have thought
something as delicious that can come out
of a can a simple supper in minutes
that's so mouth-wateringly easy and
delicious you're guaranteed to cook it
again and again
when it comes to Simple Cooking there
are two basic bits of kit on never
without that will save you time and
effort in the kitchen a grater and a
peeler the swivel peeler a stainless
steel one
that's incredible it's almost like a
lifesaver in the kitchen because they
are so quick so light swivel blade so
we've got so much more flexibility you
can actually go around the vegetable and
we call it a speed peeler in the
professional kitchen because it does
literally absolutely
rapidly peels your vegetables you have
minimal waste
and are great for everything from
peeling veg to finely slicing cheese and
making shards of chocolate a good
comfortable grip and a sharp stainless
steel blade ensures you'll always work
fast
the Box grater is another great
versatile kitchen tool and with its
Plains for cause grating fine grating
and super fine as well as blades for
slicing it's perfect for everything from
purine Ginger and zesting lemons to
shredding onions super small so they can
caramelize in a Flash and be sure to get
a solid handle to hold it firm
it's got such volume inside it doesn't
Crush everything up so I always prefer
to grate onto a tray or into a bowl so
you don't have to move it again grating
onto the board you've always got to lift
it up and place it in so Place The
Grater into a bowl and Grate too simple
but essential Speedy bits of Kit
guaranteed to make your life in the
kitchen easier
bread is a brilliant base for delicious
super fast lunches and suppers here are
three of my deliciously simple recipes
that transform a humble bit of bread
into a gastronomic treat
first up flatbreads with fennel and feta
[Music]
olive oil to a flatbread
then place in a hot frying pan and toast
until crisp and golden on both sides
these deliciously versatile breads are
made without yeast and are available in
good supermarkets and local Middle
Eastern shops
next thinly slice fresh fennel and
Scatter Over The Toasted flatbread
then toast aromatic fennel seeds in a
hot dry pan and sprinkle on top
crumble over wonderfully Tangy feta
cheese
finish with a drizzle of sweet and
sticky pomegranate molasses
bread transform before your eyes
flatbreads with fennel and feta simple
delicious and ready to eat in minutes
[Music]
my next recipe that turns a hunk of
bread into a stunning dish is bruschetta
with garlic Tomatoes Capers and pecorino
[Music]
start by slicing a baguette diagonally
to get a large surface area so it holds
more of the delicious topping
drizzle the bread with extra virgin
olive oil
then place the oil side down onto a
scorching hot griddle
when the bread is beautifully charred
remove and rub with a peeled clove of
garlic paint attention to the edges
next half sweet cherry tomatoes and rub
the juices into the toasted garlic bread
then simply crush on top
[Music]
next slice and Scatter over Tangy Caper
berries
and use a veg peeler to add shavings of
salty pecorino cheese
finally drizzle with extra virgin olive
oil and add a Twist of black pepper
fantastic fresh flavors in a flash of a
griddle pan
toast has never tasted so good
[Music]
perfect for a simple light supper or
easy lunch my next dish is the
cannellini Bean crostini with anchovy
and olive oil
foreign
first the topping heat olive oil in a
frying pan
add tin cannellini beans along with the
juices
once heated gently mash the beans with a
fork then add sliced black olives
roughly chopped parsley
and a splash of Sherry vinegar
season
[Music]
and leave on a gentle Heat
next half a festive batter
Splash with extra virgin olive oil
The Griddle pan until smoking
toast the bread oil side down
and into the pan to char evenly
curve
pop the toasty chapata with a cannellini
Bean mixture
and finish with chopped anchovies
packed with bold flavors so easy you can
always make it blindfolded ready in
under 10 minutes but eaten in seconds
three different breads three fantastic
recipes proof that even when you're
pressed for time you can still eat like
a king
incredible welcome back to my ultimate
cookery course
these are my perfect TV dinners
next up my guide to getting the best
ingredients for your money my shopping
Mantra is very simple first rely on your
senses make sure whatever you're buying
it looks smells and really feels good
and if you get the chance to taste it
before you buy it then do it second is
to recognize that knowledge is
absolutely crucial the more you know
about where your ingredients are from
and how they produce the better so don't
be scared ask lots of questions and
learn
and when you want a simple supper herbs
are perfect to use in your cooking they
add vibrancy and amazing depth of flavor
and once you get the hang of them they
are so quick and simple to use and one
woman who really knows these Chef's best
friends is expert herb grower Lorraine
Melton I love herbs I love the way you
can cook with them I love the smell of
them she's been growing an incredible
array of herbs in the wet Cambridgeshire
Countryside for over 20 years and can
smell a Bay from a basil at 50 pesos we
grow about 150 varieties of herbs it's
always interesting to grow new varieties
see what they taste like see what they
smell like it gets a bit addictive after
a while
broadly speaking you get harder herbs
and softer herbs softer herbs are things
like parsley basil rocket coriander
we grow two main types of pasta we've
got flat leaf parsley and curly parsley
flavor wise I think they're very similar
although a lot of people would say that
the flat leaf parsley has got a stronger
more aromatic flavor this is your common
basil sweet Genovese this is a purple
variety called Reuben we do Greek Basil
Thai Basil holy basil when you're
looking for a basil you want a bright
fresh basil nice leaves no blemishes and
nice strong stems it's got a lot of oils
in it and it's very strong smelling it
just tastes the summer basil Lorraine
certainly knows her stuff and she's
right soft herbs are delicate so for
maximum flavor always use them at the
end of cooking or simply add as they are
to cold dishes here are my top 5 soft
herbs that I could never live without
[Music]
basil as Lorraine said it comes in many
types all with an amazing sweet punch
and flavor great blitzed in pestos
sprinkled whole over mozzarella and
showing its versatility it even makes a
wonderful ice cream
parsley beautifully earthy and intensely
fresh use both the leaves and the stem
for great depth of flavor in savior
dressing soups and salads
coriander for an amazing hint of citrus
often used in Thai Dishes coriander is
perfect in curries and chutneys but it
bruises easily so treat it with care
tarragon a staple of French cooking this
has long soft green leaves and a
distinct antacid flavor great with
chicken or in Rich creamy sauces
finally Cherville both mild and sweet a
perfect pairing with fish an incredible
mix simply with melted butter for a
quick sauce those are my favorite soft
herbs what about the hard ones the
harder ones tends to be a more Woody
plant things like thyme Rosemary they've
got your common time which is your
ordinary General bog standard cooking
time and then you've got things like
lemon thyme we do an orange thyme which
is actually one of my favorites it
smells like thyme but it's got a deep
sort of musky scent as well which is
going to give you a slightly different
flavor in your dish
hard herbs like thyme could take more
intense cooking than soft herbs so
they're great in stews roast or pan
frying choose the right one and you can
add wonderful depth of flavor to your
dishes here are my top five I use day in
and day out
Rosemary amazingly robust with great
Bittersweet green leaves is a classic
paired with lamb delicious sprinkled
over specialty breads like Focaccia or
great as toppings for Fruity sorbets
Lorraine's favorite thyme a heavy
aromatic pungent herb which adds
delicious flavor to a Sunday roast it's
amazing with wild mushrooms and is
perfect in marinades
oregano warm and full of delicious
aromatic oils a staple of great Italian
dishes and perfect sprinkled on pizzas
or in pasta sauces
[Music]
stage a strong tasting herb with a
deliciously bitter flavor incredible in
stuffings and with Rich Meats like pork
or duck
finally Bay Bittersweet and spicy is
delicious simmered in soups stocks and
risottos and just as good dried or fresh
growing herbs is a lot easier than
people think it is on winter boxes in
balconies and it's great you can just
open your window put your hand out and
snip some off when you're out looking
for hers make sure they look nice and
healthy no blemishes stems look strong
they should just spring back it's a nice
springy sort of herbs smell obviously is
quite important not all things smell but
obviously if you think it's one that's
going to smell like lemon thyme it
should have a nice fresh lemon scent and
obviously the final one is taste you can
tip a bit off
and taste your herbs and you can see
what they taste like then
whether bought from a supermarket or
picked from your window box herbs are a
great way to add fresh flavors to your
dishes perfect for delicious simple
suppers
[Music]
even if you've got a super busy
lifestyle it doesn't mean missing out on
delicious desserts they just have to be
simple to make
when it comes to cooking at home
puddings should always be a pleasure and
never a chore and homemade puts are 100
guaranteed to impress
my next recipe has only two main
ingredients but Simplicity doesn't mean
food can't taste out of this world
incredible griddle pineapple with spice
caramel if you're making a dessert for
one or two it's gonna be quick and easy
there's some delicious griddle pineapple
fits the bill perfectly
conversations
pineapple way of testing is nice and
ripe
top of the leaves come out perfect ready
to go
always cut a pineapple with a straight
edge knife slice off the bottom
turn it back over
and slice the top part
now
keep that
for later
look at the core the center of the
pineapple and slice down
directly in half
slice that in half
take each quarter and slice them
smells incredible lay down flat and just
slice that core off
so you've got this perfect sort of boat
like pineapple slice underneath
but stop
as you get right at the end slicing
around the skin will make the pineapple
easier to eat but leaving it attached
gives you more control as it Cooks
next Heat a griddle pan as hot as you
can start off
in the corner and push it down
so you really Mark the pineapple
two minutes on each side and then just
turn them
really nice color now that beautiful
I'm going to sprinkle them
with a little touch of sugar that's
going to glaze them
now
slice the top
take out these beautiful glaze
slices of pineapple
next up the spice caramel now start off
with your pan
nice and hot
sprinkle
four tablespoons of sugar in there
just flatten it
then add the seeds from a fresh vanilla
pod in
a small dusting of Chinese five spice
never stir caramel let it sort of bubble
and transform
and she goes now I've got the color I
want it that's the perfect color off
with the gas
in with the butter then
a couple tablespoons of cream lovely and
then give that a little whisk add the
rest of your cream
and just
drip
that spicy caramel
over your pineapple
hmm
wow
simple elegant and seriously impressive
griddle pineapple with spiced caramel a
delicious treat all to yourself that
tastes even better shared
[Music]
next my tricks of the trade and kitchen
tips first up the proper way to chop
fresh herbs to get maximum flavor
chopping herbs the secret is to chop
them not bruise them now basil
is a soft herb so treat it with some
respect when people go mad chopping
herbs all the goodness comes out on the
board I want the goodness left inside
the basil place them all inside one
another with the largest Leaf at the
bottom and it's almost like rolling a
cigar large one at the bottom small ones
in the center
and then look place them down together
just roll them nice and gently don't
bruise them
step one
rolled ready to slice sharp knife
imperative fingers tucked in
the bottom part of your knuckle is the
guide between you and the herbs that
there
stops you from cutting your finger
really important to get comfortable with
a knife and just practice rolling the
knife across the board and relaxing that
wrist it's all in the wrist action so
herbs up
fingernails touch
underneath and just up and down up and
down
and there you have
a chopped basil that's not bruised
and smelling very fragrant
right coriander so you get the bunch of
coriander hold it down
and just lightly shave the leaves off
the Stalls
Bunch them up together and then just
again let the knife do the work took the
fingernails in and just chop once and
one certainly don't hack it just chop it
you can always identify when you bruise
the herb when you've removed the herbs
off the board and there's a big green
patch
[Music]
full of flavor and none of the goodness
is left on The Chopping board
a great tip for using leftover herbs
simply chop finely mix into butter roll
up in clinical and freeze
Herbie hit cut into slices and melt over
steaks chicken or veg
asparagus is great for a simple supper
to prepare always remove the Lower Woody
stem by gently bending and the asparagus
will snap at the perfect point
then boil Steam and serve with a little
of my herb butter
for a cracking soft boiled egg simply
place your egg in boiling water add a
splash of vinegar and cook for exactly
eight minutes
then plunge into ice water the vinegar
helps the shell peel off easily and the
Ice Water stops the egg from cooking
giving you the perfect runny yolk
[Music]
for fuss-free salad dressings simply add
the ingredients into a Jam Jar screw the
lid on tightly and Shake to combine in
seconds there's no need to wash up a
whisk and the jar is ready made to store
any leftovers
Follow My ultimate cookery course
bursting with valuable lessons
top tips and 100 recipes to take your
take your fun and you'll literally be
cooking yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking